all right Giovanni
Giovanni where'd you grow up where are
you from originally I'm from Los Angeles
California
what part Compton
tell me about your uh your parents
growing up
um it was hectic a lot of problems a lot
of fighting
money problems
where you closer to mom or dad my dad
yeah
are you how far you go to school
I went to the eighth grade
then I dropped out and started gang
banging I got kicked out the house
how'd your parents feel about that about
which part dropping out in eighth grade
I got kicked out basically out the
district
because the fighting gang violence
when she joined the gang what kind of
stuff are you getting into
a little bit of everything but mostly
like home invasions
that was my thing to do
I just stuck to that and
it just it was going well at first and
then I just got too greedy
so you're it was Mexican King yeah I saw
them again are you Mexican no I'm
Sicilian no so you're you're a white boy
in a Mexican gang yeah how was that
um
it was kind of hard
but
you just gotta show them that you're
there you know that you're you're for
the game
you're in prison time
yeah plenty
for what kind of stuff uh
armed robbery
home invasion
kidnapping and home invasion and
residentials
holding her I'm 30 years old
where'd you stay now I stand right here
in downtown L.A you're on the streets
yeah no I'm getting a matter of fact I'm
saying my lease from my apartment today
oh you are yes sir good for you thank
you how do you make money
ah a little bit of here a little bit of
that
are drugs a part of your life yeah
what's your drug now weed and crystal
meth
what does crystal meth do for you
um
I
mostly I think it's just a social thing
I'm so used to just doing it and
everybody basically I'm around does it
so it's
a social thing
but it's all they think
and all night too right yeah you don't
sleep no
how many days you will you go without
sleeping ah the most I've done is 12
days 12 days of no sleep yes
wow
you get a little 10 seconds 30 seconds
but yeah and you realize you go you're
going to sleep you're back up
how's your behavior change if you're
going a bunch of days without sleep
drastically like you don't think
straight
your mind's not working with you your
your mind's not connecting with your
body
so it's basically the mind the one thing
and the body's not even there it's just
go
you're just exhausting your body
looking back at your life do you do you
regret the path you took dropping out of
school joining a gang
I regret to jumping out of school
everything else no
it taught me things that
I would not learned in a regular
environment
what kind of things have you learned
from the streets
that everybody's not
there to help you everybody's not
your friend everybody's not
for you everybody don't want to see you
succeed
everybody that says they're your friends
they're your homie
your A1 whatever those are the ones that
are going to stab you in the back even
worse
do you have kids yes where are they
uh they're with their mom
or you you don't see them very often I
see them probably just holidays yeah and
that's it
what emotions do you go through with
this lifestyle man
um
I'll say a lot of regret
a lot of
hurt
and
a lot of just thought you know
what's your biggest regret
not being there when my dad passed away
what's your biggest fear
oh I already happened
my dad passing away and your daughter's
in prison
getting the calling home on Christmas
and finding out he passed
how does that change your attitude or
your behavior in every way fully
like if before I cared a little bit
no I don't care
I don't got that person that
I would like to be out here for
and
that person that would always I mean
watch better for me and always remind me
that I'm loved regardless no matter what
whether right or wrong he was always
there
you feel like you're on your own now
yeah just you against everyone else yeah
what was your favorite memory as a kid
going truck driving with my dad he used
to be a truck driver and I used to go
with him every summer every uh vocations
I had I'll go with them
everywhere I've been to every state I've
been all the way to borderline Canada
and the United States
everywhere
where'd your dad think of you joining a
gang
he didn't like it
he did not agree with that at all
he used to want me to truck driver like
him but
I told him that was not for me that I
wanted the street life
since I was little I just tell him I
want to be like that I want to be tatted
up like that I want to be with the
homies like that
and that's what I that's what I ended up
doing and you're still
you're still of that attitude
yeah
especially not him
pops is gone you know
like
my mom really is not
there for
communication and emotional you know
she's just more of a okay let me know
you're okay and that's it
so it's just basically like a two three
second phone call hey you're right yeah
okay bye
it's been the roughest point of your
life
losing my dad and getting out to
all the memories and all the places we
went to
your dad was such a big part of your
life it sounds like major
what do you think he
'd say if you were if you're looking at
where you're at today
I know what he would say I exactly know
what he would say
that I'm not a little kid I'm going to
give my act right and act like man I got
kids
but
it's not easy
it's not easy when you go through
different trials difference like issues
every day
like on the streets there's not a day
that you don't have an issue
it
and if you're not looking for issues
it's just going to come to you
but some of the craziest things you've
seen from your years in the streets
man the craziest I've seen and it's been
recent
I've seen a dude's brains get blown out
literally on 6th and San Pedro
little
from when the gunfire started going off
to where he got hit
he died yeah right there on the spot
the driver of the car pulled them out
and pulled out a kid from the back seat
and I don't know how to react at the
moment yeah I've seen crazy things done
crazy things but that
just seen it
it's like
it's not real like
no
no it doesn't make you question whether
this is the right lifestyle for you
no
and I'm being honest because I know the
consequences that come with it I know
the risks that come with it and
I chose to take on those risks
you have to watch your back when you
wherever you go at all times
I like I said I don't trust nobody I
don't give my trust to everybody fully
you might think I am but I'm not
you can't you can't be all smiles in
front of these people these people are
hungry for whatever you have that they
don't have
he's getting off the streets and living
a square life is scary is it
intimidating
no because I've done it you've done it
I've done it but
who says that that's for everybody
though you know
like I know I could do it but
who knows like
anybody could just oh whatever and get
up and go you know
all right one day you're in a bad mood
and something happens and you snap in
the wrong way
and there goes your your free time you
know you you put away
so
I've never
let's say plan or think about the next
day until the next day comes
would you like to be in five years
what would I like to be in five years
man I own in my own house probably
having a little business I'm
planning of having
you think the the life you're leading
now could lead to that
yes and no
do you find yourself being
self-destructive sometimes yes
and a lot of times
I think it's just more of
like
let's see when it's my turn you know
like
man I recently like probably like a
month ago I said I got stabbed six times
over a bike
and
I thought I was fighting the dude
he pulled out stabbed me twice I kept
fighting him stabbed me twice two more
times
and then the last one was on my neck he
was like an inch away from from the main
artery
I died at the hospital for a minute 30.
and I was in ICU and I
personally discharged just to go find
the individual that did that to me
did you find him uh yeah I found him
what'd you do
took care of business
you're not gonna have one up on me
you're not
because
you literally almost left my kids
without a father you know
and that's the worst part about it
like I
I really don't think about myself in
that situation I think more about my
kids
like how would it be
to have your mom tell you hey your dad
died or
hey that's not around no more
so that's what what was going through my
mind at that moment
so you were brought here by one of the
transgender women that works skid row
you're friendly with them yes
and what kind of relationships do you
have with them
um
I've dated a couple
uh very close friends with a couple
and
yeah just involved in that lifestyle is
it is that controversial does that cause
problems for you on the streets
it used to a lot now that people know
and people see me around a lot
the more like okay
all right that's him you know and he
doesn't try that with with
anybody else just with the P that crowd
you know yeah
the world the world is changing very
much something that's becoming more and
more acceptable I guess yeah
very little right
no it could it could it could
cost you your life basically
that's a No-No is that part of what
attracts you to the streets
is that whole scene that goes on down no
because that scene came to me when I was
in prison
so
yeah it was in the streets it's just
I guess that crowded it's interesting
it's different you know it's it's
I wouldn't I wouldn't give it up at all
like I would that's that tells you
everything yeah I wouldn't
you been in love before
is that been difficult or it was
difficult good experience
it was it was a little bit of both yeah
always is
um
because I'm like out of my dad showing
me the Loving Care
out here on the street side and have
that except what we call Loving Care
from the homies right but
it's not the same as having that
person there that you know is always
there
so yeah she used to be there all the
time
but would not be outside of mine in jail
it'll be a whole different story
this time that I got out
she got arrested like three months
before
a carjacking in Vegas
and now she's doing 14 years in Nevada
prison
what is it about the streets that was
attractive to you
the money
the money the fame
and just
knowing that people don't want to see
you succeed and that when you're
succeeding like
that aggravates people like
man [ __ ] him he's man
he'll lose that later on or we'll take
that later you know but
in reality
maybe ask the person for help hey how'd
you do it
or what I mean give me some tips
something like instead of harming the
person instead of taking them back steps
you mean
like
help help yourself go ahead
and not
the other person go back you know what
I'm saying let's both succeed why not
why not
it just seems like violence is the
solution in this lifestyle yeah this
they're so quick to pick up guns
they're so quick to pick up a weapon
so it's like of course everybody oh
first thing is the fear oh I'm gonna get
shot
or I'm gonna get uh they're gonna judge
me and I'm gonna die like
Giovanni what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
don't trust don't trust the people that
are closer to you
don't open up fully to everybody
not even to your loved ones because your
loved ones will do you wrong as well
there's no such thing as blood is
thicker than water
there's no such thing
and I could tell you from experience
all right Giovanni thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you good luck
out there likewise on the streets